they make it their business to mind your
business after winning a local election
in Iran this woman was declared too sexy
for government by religious officials
who barred her from holding office even
smelled blue virtually anywhere not so
fast
Miramax crusade to save New Yorkers from
themselves now extends to e-cigarettes
even though they're a little more than
steam with nicotine you're telling next
smokers to go back to cigarettes as dr.
Michael Siegel of Boston University's
School of Public Health but this time we
head to Palo Alto California I've
recently lost my job my wife at my house
now I live on an RV in a commercial zone
please don't criminalize me
it'll cost you about twenty five hundred
bucks a month to rent a one-bedroom
apartment in this ritzy Bay Area
community and the City Council has
criminalized the much cheaper option of
sleeping in your car that makes tough
economic times even tougher for people
like Diane Jones who recently became
homeless and lives in a car with her son
so I'm begging you this is hard
thank you violators could face up to six
months in jail but the mayor defends the
ordinance saying it provides police with
a much needed crime-fighting tool so if
someone's urinating was living in front
of someone's house urinating on their
front yard or defecating on their front
yard the police can ask them to move
along maybe someone could tell the mayor
that that sort of thing is already
illegal followed an Andy the month on
Twitter submit your nanny nominees and
click here to watch another episode
[Music]
you